using a controller to play PC games is nothing new but valve wants to give you more options while playing on Steam I'm Tony and this is your expanded game spot news update at this year's steam dev days conference valve engineer Jeff Belling Heusen announced an update to steam that adds configurability options to DualShock 4 controllers the DualShock is fairly similar to the steam controller thanks to its gyro and touchpad & Belling housing showed a picture of what this configuration could look like it'll be interesting to see how Steam users program their controllers differently these options are coming to DualShock for first but other controllers will receive similar upgrades down the road we've talked at length about whether or not the steam controller can replace your keyboard and mouse so we'll see if you can do the same with a dual shock to keep up with all the biggest steam announcements you're already in the right place you